alexander skarsgard and margot robbie
sure look the part but how do they
measure up to disney's original tarzan
and jane
tarzan jane
jane 2016's the legend of tarzan trades
animal animation for epic cgi
but there are a few things missing like
best friends turk and tantor however the
2016 version is actually a lot closer to
tarzan's origins than you might think
from how they mastered that epic ape
battle to the voices behind the disney
original here's a look behind the scenes
at the making of tarzan
and all the most interesting changes
tricks and movie magic
used to create the jungle dweller's wild
world so how you want to play this thing
the leader will come down and we'll
fight
originally published in 1912 tarzan of
the apes by edgar rice burroughs was the
first of 24 novels about an orphan who's
raised by primates the book has pretty
much
everything the movies do there's vine
swinging monkey fights and of course
jane burroughs claimed his story was
loosely based on a myth about twin
brothers romulus and remus who
instead of their parents being
shipwrecked in a jungle like tarzan's
were sentenced to be drowned to prevent
them from claiming their uncle's throne
they wound up floating down the river
and were found by a wolf and a
woodpecker
instead of the motherly ape who finds
tarzan so where is his mama
well i'm going to be his mother now but
there's also evidence that the story
could have been inspired by a real
person
the 14th earl of stratham william
charles milden
after his passing he left 1500
hand-written pages of memoirs detailing
his adventures after being marooned in
the jungle
and taken in by apes though unlike
tarzan he never became their leader
instead he eventually left them to join
a local tribe which is much more similar
to the path tarzan takes in the 2016
film
and learned to be as one with them the
biggest difference between the two
movies is how their star-studded casts
got to portray their characters disney
had an amazing team of voice actors
behind the 1999 classic
tony goldwyn and minnie driver voiced
tarzan and jane while glenn close took
on the role of calla and rosie o'donnell
was the voice of turk for tony the
inspiration behind tarzan came from
picturing a guy who was really into
extreme sports which makes sense with
all that tree surfing and vine swinging
as for jane minnie driver's emotive
performance was used to create jane's
exaggerated facial expressions
so she was really expressive so we took
that and put it into the design
the legend of tarzan didn't rely on
animation but focused more on a mix of
live action
and cgi it was directed by david yates
who also did the last four harry potter
films so he's no stranger to epic
special effects
as for the casting margot robbie was an
easy choice for jane and alexander
skarsgard is almost the spitting image
of tarzan although he's definitely more
serious
a lot of the filming environment wasn't
lush jungle instead it was green screen
and props so the actors had to work in a
similar way to the voice actors they had
to imagine what the final product might
actually look like so they could seem
convincing when they were faced with
people in grey suits who would later be
transformed into some scary looking apes
that's a coot you sure you don't want me
to shoot him
both films follow the general plot of
the book but with a few key differences
though none of the versions are nice to
tarzan's parents in the book calla takes
tarzan
in as a replacement for her own lost
baby in both film adaptations tarzan's
parents become stranded and start to
make a home for themselves in an
abandoned tree house
tarzan ends up an orphan but the
animation has his parents attacked by
jaguars while in the live
action he loses his mother first to
illness and then his father is attacked
by apes before kala finds tarzan
now i fear for my child when all these
events take place is really up to the
specific plot of each film
for disney jane and her father's trek
through the jungle was due to british
expansion
tarzan's family is shipwrecked around
1860 and he meets jane around
1880. the live action starts out around
1885 because tarzan is already an adult
and staying in britain and my name isn't
it's john clayton iii this makes sense
since britain was still using
expeditions as a source of power
hence king leopold ii claiming the congo
both versions make historical sense but
the live action puts a lot more effort
into the expansion plot that leads to
tarzan's home being attacked though that
doesn't necessarily make the movie more
fun
i think this one will be better off
stuffed
thankfully the iconic moment where
tarzan meets jane is portrayed in
every adaptation by the time they meet
in the book tarzan has already become
king of the apes jane is there with her
father
searching for lost treasure while in the
disney version her and her father
are researchers on an expedition the
live action is similar with them
exploring africa on behalf of the king
except they've already heard stories
about a strange man living in the jungle
lord of the apes king of the jungle me
tarzan eugene
in the animation jane is lost and soon
meets tarzan compared to her playing
hide and seek in the live action when
tarzan steals her handkerchief
both versions have that awkward but
hilarious moment where tarzan smells
jane to say hi
as for how jane looks in these moments
both films are inspired by victorian
fashion
even though we kind of miss jane's
classic yellow dress
it can't get any worse can it
despite all the adaptations sticking to
similar versions of jane
disney's version is the only one that
has tarzan's two best friends
turk and tantor the rebellious young ape
and the germaphobic elephant have a lot
of fun in the animation and the voice
actors didn't have a hard time getting
into their outrageous roles
i didn't do anything because i feel i
have innate gorilla tendencies
as for the animators they studied apes
and elephants in their natural
environments before working on character
design
legend of tarzan doesn't portray this
friendship the character design is more
realistic
and focuses on apes like kala and a cut
this version is more true to the book
but we can see why fans of the disney
version thought it was a bit boring the
special effects team
studied ape behavior to design the
characters but it's more planet of the
apes and less jungle book yeah well
good friends uh huh speaking of a cut
his fight with tarzan in the 2016 film
replaces the epic eight battle in the
disney version where tarzan fights
carla's mate
kerchak kerchak hates tarzan when he's
young and in the live action a cut is
called his biological son who feels
betrayed when tarzan leaves for england
he's my brother once and now he'll
consider me a deserter
like kerczyk a cut eventually becomes
the leader of the apes to film the scene
where tarzan fights a cut the filmmakers
designed a padded suit and a transparent
helmet to make the stuntman look as
large as an ape for the disney version
the animator studied what territorial
fights between apes look like in the
wild
but what about tarzan's human co-stars
in the disney version
jane and her father are tarzan's first
real encounter with people
this adaptation only includes jane her
father and the other explorers the live
action sees tarzan facing a lot more
human foes and it definitely makes sense
that he would eventually mingle with
other tribes in the jungle
tarzan you look funny the film even
includes a rival village where tarzan is
hated because he off the leader's son as
revenge for kala
his biggest enemy is also different in
the disney version it's clayton
voiced by brian blest while in the live
action it's leon rahm
portrayed by christoph waltz take a
tarzan with you
the future was almost me to keep with
the serious tone the jungle expedition
in the legend of tarzan has a completely
different purpose than the disney
version
the congo basin is claimed by king
leopold ii and he's accused of
exploiting its resources
this is what convinces tarzan to return
home to the jungle
disney's version shows that jane and her
father are under the impression that
they're there for innocent research
purposes but the other explorers know
they're
actually there to capture the apes and
bring them back to england power and
money definitely drive both teams of
explorers with the disney version being
slightly easier to thwart
what this should do the trick now how
about tarzan and jane's happy ending
both films end with the couple choosing
the jungle but they get there in pretty
different ways for one
the live action starts out with tarzan
as john clayton iii and he's gone back
to england to live a normal life with
jane
in the disney version we never see
tarzan in this kind of stuffy
environment he thinks about joining jane
in england but instead they both decide
that the apes are probably better than
people the live-action version focuses
on tarzan's acclimation to high society
life but by the end they can't resist
the call of the jungle
they speak of his power over the animals
of the jungle
finally we have to mention how both
versions manage to perfectly capture
tarzan's wild jungle antics like how he
swung so easily from tree to tree
the legend of tarzan used a completely
cg character based on a cirque du soleil
trapeze artist and just movie magicked
skarsgard's
face onto the digital model it took 16
cameras to properly capture his face
so they could pull off this trick in the
disney version 3d animation was used to
make the sliding and swinging seem so
fluid
how'd you know it's me i'm your mother i
know everything now where have you been
so do you prefer the classic animation
to the live action tarzan are there any
changes that make the live action better
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time